Actually unusual for me to talk to
people who barely know me and my work,
but also they give him five minutes to
summarize my entire career and then have
a conversation. But, um,
but it's actually more interesting to
talk to people who don't know anything
about my work. But as you explained, um,
I am Iranian born but I've lived in the
u s I think now longer than in my own
country. And, um, the first, uh,
body of work that I made after being
proven to be a terrible painter was
photography. And, um, actually
I'm not a photographer.
I don't even own a camera.
I actually hire photographers,
site director photography,
and then I deal with, um,
the process after. Um, but I'm just going
to, since I want to speak very little,
I have a conversation. The first
serious body of my work, um,
after 10 years of not working at all at
art was a group of work called woman of
Allah.
And this is basically a
series of photographs that I
did and that sort of really
focused on the Islamic revolution in 1979.
And the role of woman in militancy during
the Islamic revolution and the whole
concept of martyrdom and the idea of being
a murderer and what it meant in terms
of being in this intersection of love
of God and yet cruelty and violence and
death. Um, and in for
most of those photographs,
I post myself and I photographed friends.
Um,
and this photography continued
later on after I made many movies,
uh, into this book, a series
called the book of Kings,
which was like over 10 years
later. And it really was about, um,
the 2009 green movement in Iran.
Now it's more than 10 years
is far more. Um, but it again,
it captures another pivotal moment,
Iranian history.
If the first one was Islamic revolution,
this shows them more modern, uh,
Iranian society,
but still battling with people were
fighting against tyranny and political
oppression, etc. So this body
of work was about, I don't know,
65 photographs.
I'm going rather quickly.
But what you'll see constantly
is the female body. Uh,
I mean the male and female body being
a significant part of my photographs.
And obviously this inscription
of texts that were, uh,
poetry by people of Iran. Um, and, um,
so now I'm going again quickly. This is
another body of work that I did in Egypt,
uh, which was immediately
after the Arab spring.
And that sort of captured the notion of
patriotism and the euphoria around the
revolutions that we experience
all over the Middle East,
yet the terrible aftermath, which was, uh,
a lot of genocide and
death. Um, the next group,
big group of photographs I created
in 2015 and 16 was in Azerbaijan,
which previously was a part of my own
country called the home of my eyes.
And in this series I basically acted
more like a documentary artists.
I photographed the local people and as I,
by John being a place of mixed
ethnicities from Turks, Armenians,
Persians and Russians.
Uh,
but all of the people that I photograph
had common hand postures that were very
similar to the cushion payments
that are Greg paintings.
And the team being the idea of home or
the absence of home and what meant to
these people.
They're little inscriptions written
all over their bodies that are there
transcripts of the
interviews that I conducted.
I make a lot of videos.
I've been active in media of video since
1998 and this was my breakthrough into
the art world with video,
which won the golden lion
in Venice biannual. Um,
but again, it was literally taking
the aesthetics on my photographs,
but having it move and that having music
and choreography and a story that had a
beginning, middle and the end. This
is another piece fervor, which again,
it became a little bit more narrative,
but as you can see,
they're highly stylized
and very fictionalize.
And, um, these were all shot in Morocco.
So by now I began to shoot videos and
films outside of us must be in Morocco and
Egypt and Turkey in different places.
So these are examples
that said, okay. Um, and,
and so the next thing I wanted to share
with you is that since 2000 known yeah,
since 2002 I've been very
busy making feature films.
I made a film called women without men
that was based on a magic realist novel
that won in the Silver Lion
Award in Venice Film Festival.
That took six years.
And I just completed this new film
looking for Omakase assume that, uh,
we will show some clips. Um, but that
was based on Egyptian singer in Egypt.
And I spent 12 years
making two feature films
and I did an opera. So that said,
we go right to the conversation
being an Iranian female living in New
York. This informs a lot of your work.
You lived in exile basically
in the United States. Can,
can you talk about what it was like to
have that happen and what your return to
Iran was like given that that was sort of
the starting point of all of your work?
Well at the time, and
I grew up, there was a,
a lot of Iranian families were sending
their children abroad to study because
lack of, um, you know, situations
at colleges, universities.
And so the,
we were all sent out the,
we didn't predict the revolution.
And at that time,
my father sent me and
my sisters and brothers,
they all went back and I happened to be
in the u s when the revolution happened.
And, um, so unfortunately at
that time I was very young.
I came when I was 17 and
the Russian happened. Um,
I was in college actually.
I was at UC Berkeley.
And immediately after the revolution,
they took over the American embassy
in Iran. The hostages were taken.
So there was an incredibly strong
anti American sentiment. Um,
so I found myself alone in a country
without financial help and without the,
and the loving family
around me. Um, but also, um,
against the wall politically as
there was a strong reaction. Um,
so I didn't see them, not for
the 20 years, but 11 years.
I didn't go back. And, um, and
eventually when I went back,
I started to make art and then the,
the country,
the government found my work problematic.
And then since 1996,
I have not been back.
Wow. And I think that sort of leads us in
when you said the government found your
work problematic.
You're work is highly political and
you often talk about having a social
responsibility.
So I was wondering if you can talk
about the idea of being the voice of a
country that you haven't lived
in in a very long time. You know,
you don't have the possibility,
uh,
to distance yourself from the
political reality. And is,
is that the political consciousness
is something that is not a choice.
And I think that's difficult for Americans
to understand that if your everyday
life is defined by a this and that,
for example, this reason breakdown,
you know, again, the, the exit
of America from the nuclear deal,
it's a huge issue for my family in Iran,
for me and the future of us
as immigrants. And so, um,
so I think the work is a manifestation
is kind of artistic reflection on the
political reality, but it's
not, it's not a propaganda.
It is rather a kind of a fictional work
that somehow tries to shed light on the
complexity of the situation.
And so I don't see myself as the voice
of the country or, but the fact that,
um, my work has, um,
properties in the way that it communicates
about the people and to the people.
If you're on well, you've
made, you've made photographs,
you've made short films,
you've made feature length films.
Can you talk about how your process
changes between each medium?
Well, it's a, I think that, uh,
this kind of nomadic behaviors,
a little bit of my personality because
I'm extremely restless and nervous.
Yeah. And all of his living
in a very nomadic lifestyle.
And I'm never anywhere for very long.
People like me.
And I think a lot of us are like that.
And,
and that we turned to learn very
quickly a new places, new languages,
new food, new environment. It's
just a way of life. So it's not,
we're not really fixed at any place,
any situation.
And so somehow I feel like this lifestyle
has also been my relationship to the
mediums that I'm not really
faithful to anything.
I'm not really good at anything and I
haven't been really thinking you're good
at. I'm not educated in it, but I,
I spent a lot of times, like I said,
I spent six years making a film.
So I spend a lot of time
studying whatever I'm doing,
but I give myself the license
to feel adventurous and uh, and,
and also to struggle and
beyond that edge because I,
she like by embracing a new medium,
you really inventing yourself and that's
often keeping yourself excited as a,
as an artist, as a human being,
that even as you get old,
you feel young and you fail.
And I think that's been nice.
My nature as a person and I think in
a way that informs the way I work.
What's the process?
Over six years of making,
I do other things as well because I
have source of survivors and artist.
I do exhibitions. Um, the process
of the film has been, first of all,
it's a script writing and then
finding the right producers,
then finding the money,
location scouting and actually casting,
etc. And,
uh,
I think the two films have been the
most painful experience I've ever had.
Worst thing giving birth to a child,
but the point is that at the end of it,
I feel like it's a great
accomplishment in some ways.
I think every frame of the film becomes
a photograph and every few minutes
becomes a video installation.
And that also you're able to communicate
to a larger audience that are not just
gallery,
museum goers and you're really thinking
about the masses and the general public.
And I think that gives
me a great pleasure.
Wow. Um, so I think that's a
good point for us to turn to.
Looking for a home called Tim,
which is your most recent film project,
one of these projects that has
taken a very long time to complete,
it's a movie within a movie.
It's about a Persian directors attempts
to film the life and legacy of the
Egyptian singer called Tomb.
Um,
can you give us a little bit of the
backstory about how you discovered her,
why she was so fascinating to you?
But first of all,
I'd have to say that even though my
work looks very sociopolitical on the
surface, it, there's always something
they personal about the work.
It's always been about my experience,
my perspective, not my experience,
the way I viewed things. That
way I find my questions. And,
and so it has this very
personal, um, um, approach, uh,
with looking for Onco zoom.
Zoom is the biggest,
the most important artists of the 20th
century in the middle is without a doubt.
He happened to be a woman, happened to
be gay, happened to be non traditional.
She never got married, she never had
children. And yet she's loved by men,
by women. The Sunday news is she
is secular and ours, you know,
so Cuellar and from Israel
to Saudi Arabia to Iran to,
it's an amazing phenomena.
And so this film is about an
Iranian woman artist living in Aza,
uh, questioning the, the, the success
of the iconic artists from them,
that ease and really facing the
question of how can be as women become
successful,
uh,
and does this mean that we have to
sacrifice personal lives and, uh,
issues that are deeply traditional
expectations from a woman.
And so this woman and myself,
I've had a child and single mother.
And so how do you navigate between,
you know,
romantic life and traditional
role as mothers, but yet, uh,
pursue your passion and pursued
your career and be successful.
So it's really a question of a smaller
artist to an iconic artists. And,
and of course the script
was impossible and you know,
so if you call in and
out of a period film too,
so the film behind that and a highly
controversial because she's the biggest
artists of Egypt.
Um,
so it's been showing in the Arab
world and interesting reactions.
That's actually one of the things we
wanted to ask you about is how was it
perceived in Egypt and in Iran?
Well, the Iranians are upset.
They said,
what can you find an iconic woman singer?
Why do you have to go to Egypt?
Because there's no Iranian artists
as ever reached that popularity. Um,
and I needed a break from Iran. Um, but I
think with the Egyptians, um, it's been,
uh, really at the beginning they
were like, what you, I mean,
not even Egyptians are there to make a
film about her because she's too sacred
and untouchable. And
some people say, in fact,
maybe this was the best
way to approach it.
I think it film inside of a film because
we were very honest about this, that,
you know, this isn't a time, this
is the vision of Iranian artists.
This is not a documentary.
This is not a biopic.
This is not exactly the story,
but this is the way this woman is
struggling to tell the story. Um,
and I went with the film to
Tunisia, it in Egypt, in Lebanon.
It's opening in Morocco and you know,
of course in a small scale and um, but,
but it's interesting that the film is
finding its audience and I think it is not
ever a film that would have
a huge audience and he's
not targeting a commercial
audience. But I think it's
something that would last,
it would have a life a
longer because it's a really,
an artistic project is not meant to be,
you know,
anything that you'll see and you know,
Union Square,
what do you call them? The
movie theater. Regal cinema.
If he's lucky somewhere you
didn't take it to Toronto though.
And they were opening more
mouth for a week in July 26. Uh,
and uh, it will have a week
run, which I'm very happy about.
So go see it.
Um,
what was it like to sort of take it to
the Toronto Film Festival? What was, um,
what's it like?
You've done a lot of film festivals,
you've taken things on the circuit.
How does that,
this one made me very nervous because,
uh,
first of the second term is
very difficult as so, uh,
it was an Arab story.
And I'm not Arab.
So a lot of the audience often are
Arab and I know you're like, Oh God,
they're going to like throw tomatoes
at me. Um, and also that is,
it's a very artistic film,
so you always have a mix.
It's always sold out.
The screenings are full and because
people love her and everything, but,
and there's always a great mix
of receptions and people who, uh,
critics who don't like it,
who like it,
I have absolutely don't relate to it,
to those who appreciate it.
So like everything I've done,
it's never ever like praise
completely or destroyed,
but I'm still going on. Um, so it's a mix,
but I think slowly it's
finding its audience.
And in terms of the story and the main
character in the film seems to have some
reflection of you in terms of,
um, it's a female director.
She encounters, um, some
pushback from being a female,
um,
from being Persian.
Is this personal?
It's about my experience.
It's about, um, you know,
my own struggles to make this
film my own shortcomings.
Even the script we wrote is problematic.
It's not a perfect script.
And this woman also
struggles with the script.
It was just impossible to know how to
go under the skin of this incredible,
incredible woman that was a myth. You
know, it was not even a human. And she,
she actually wanted to remain as an image.
So what I asked for,
it was an impossible task to devour
and demystify a myth that it was just
impossible. So, so in this film I tried
to be really honest about, you know,
I chose a very difficult subject
and I didn't completely succeed and,
but, but, but what did I learn about
this from her? And what was the angle?
What was the obsession about?
And I think then when you get
the intimate about the process,
there's honesty about the
film that, you know, then if,
if you are that kind of person,
you understand this film,
by no means try to be pretentious
or trying to compare me with her,
but really showing the artistic practice
involving a lot of struggles and
failures of an artist,
but also doubts.
And I think that's something that
we don't give credit to the artist,
but the process,
it's often painful and it involves
taking the risk and that doesn't always
succeed in a positive way. But
that is part of the process. And I,
that's all I tried to show and
even the film has at the final,
it's not a perfect film and
I'm the first one to say it,
but I think that's what it was all about,
you know?
And what do you think is so imperfect
about it? The script I think, um,
because you know, again, um,
the way that we try to navigate between
different periods and the story of the
Iranian woman versus the story of
this iconic artists and how to balance
everything between the political
reality when she lived her own political
reality as a woman in [inaudible],
there's a lot of information there is,
there is a lot of metaphorical
meanings that we wanted to,
to weave into the story that about woman,
about being artists that are living within
political reality that affects their
work and their success and failures.
And me as an exotic artist,
she is the one who,
who became very loyal to the political
leaders in order to stay successful.
So there was just so much intentions
that we tried to build into the narrative
that maybe just wasn't
perfect, you know? Um, and,
and I think that's okay.
It's totally okay.
And I think one of the things that's
interesting is obviously this fits into
your larger practice in
terms of um, uh, you know,
in Islamic female protagonist,
but you,
you often talking about that you're more
interested in form then you are in the
content.
And so I was wondering if you can talk
a little bit about how making narrative
films sort of fits into your
larger practice of photography,
of sort of short
experimental film. Um, and,
and if you think you
were successful there,
and I'm glad you said that because they
often people just focus on the scene
because I'm Iranian,
but in fact I think I consider
myself among some of the western,
also artists who are beginning to break
through the way from the museum and
Gallery walls and tried to experiment
with what it's like for visual artists to
tell the story, what kind
of form would it take, uh,
without mimicking conventional cinema,
but also not making things that
are completely incomprehensible.
I also directed opera last read,
Salzburg Festival,
Ada and I sort of go and,
and Ricardo Muti the conductor and
what is the nature of ambitiousness
experimentation. But I think that is
happening more and more where, um,
both at film festivals,
the music festivals,
and are really welcoming artists coming
from other mediums to experimenting with
this. And, and I have to say that,
um, I, you know, I do photography,
I do video installations, I do film,
I'm making a new song, uh, and,
and I, you know, still do performing arts.
And not because I'm good at all of these
things because I enjoy the process and
I think it's good to
give yourself, um, the,
the goal of being able not to stay
stagnated within one form of work.
I could have stayed with those pictures,
writing calligraphy for
the rest of my life,
make a bundle of money and make
zero money making some, in fact,
I put everything I have from
the photography into the film.
So it's a kind of stupid because
there's money never paid a place, uh,
in its equation. And, and so I
think that's a decision I made.
It's a true labor.
I think it is an eye.
I stand behind it and I
will never be very rich.
You mentioned the Ahhbra,
something that you said that I really
thought was interesting was you said
sometimes the boundaries between
Ada and myself are blurred.
MMM.
What do you mean by that?
What's your relationship to Aida?
I either is the story of its European
businesses in exile in Egypt.
And the director of the music festival,
uh,
invited me because I either
just historically has been
highly problematic, uh,
opera for,
for a lot of middle easterners because
it's the most cliche and orientalist I
opera. And that sort of,
um, badly stereotypes.
The Middle Eastern, even in the
ancient times, each have an inner tube.
Ian's make them into this very
barbaric, um, you know, and,
and then the westerners are the glory
of know it's written by an Italian
composer Verde. And so he found it very
interesting that if I could take this,
which was a huge task, um, Eh,
this narrative and sort of maybe a new
reinterpretation of it that somehow kept
the grandiose, uh, of
the classical Aida and,
and didn't compromise the value of it,
um,
but yet was able to address
the kind of cliche and,
and sort of it didn't have the elephants
and the horses and the people painted
black walking.
So I took three years and I had to
do it is also very controversial,
is never done in this way. Um, but um,
it was completely successful in the
way that was really highly attended,
but it was also very controversial.
That sounds like a huge undertaking as
are a lot of your films now that you're
doing,
you're doing really elaborate projects.
And I want to turn back a little bit to,
to your work with film,
one of the films or short films that
you started with with turbulent,
you went to women without men
that you mentioned before.
What sort of happening on your
path with film right now and, um,
they have this undercurrent or at
least turbulent does about music. Um,
when you talk about the power of music,
so you're a visual artist
who is using music. Um,
yeah,
I mean I think again,
because so much of my works about the
sociopolitical religious realities,
music brings with it, its something
they, a gospel, very emotional,
something that doesn't need translation.
Uh,
I think that helps in a way
neutralized someone saying, Eh,
that political content of my work.
Um,
and because I think my work is as
much about existential universal,
timeless and emotional issues as it is
about today's realities and political
realities. And I just want to take
this point and just mentioned that, uh,
another reason that I go toward very
stylized of surrealistic narrative like
woman would happen then was based
on a magic realist novel. And, and,
and the reason I feel so comfortable
with dreams and surrealism is because it
allows you to make reference to reality,
but yet also staying in another place
that sort of gives you some space from
that.
And the current film that I'm working,
I think it's the first time
I really talk about it,
it's called Dreamland and it's
really in a summarized way,
is about this surrealistic novel
that would be shot in the u s uh,
about Iranian people
spying on Americans dreams.
Um, and, and, and his episode,
there's a political satire,
but it really is a,
is institution is Kinda Evanion colony
that is the future of Trump doing with
Iranian people. I would say refugee
camp full of Iranian people,
but sort of oddly,
and ironically there is an institution
within this colony that it's actually a
room for interpretation of
American people's dreams.
And there's a woman who every day goes
on the highway to a small little American
town and her job is secretly,
she goes as a census worker,
the door to door to people's homes asking
information at the end she says, I'm,
what is your last dream? People say
dreams that we have to uh, Jennifer, yes,
it's part of the survey from Washington.
So she was a spy,
but she carries their photographs and
their dreams back to that call and so they
can interpret the dream.
So,
so my idea again of creating a
narrative that there is symbolically and
absolutely absurd and fat tire go away.
It's sort of critiques this, um,
tension between two countries.
The superpower would dominate the
world, uh, and the fanaticism,
right?
That exists in the upsert
Iranian government and that
the humanity in between
the two parts and, and,
and, you know, so there's a,
this is the story we're doing and
I'm hoping we can shoot it 2019.
Wow. Well, we look at
forward to seeing that and um,
there are so many dichotomies in
your work including this sort of, um,
play with reality versus
sort of these more magical,
fantastical, um, sort of aesthetics
that you even bring into Miquel tomb.
And there is a sort of abuse
attention between the beauty and, um,
and also, you know, the undercurrent
of what you're, you're having to say.
I think that's, you put your finger
on absolutely the right thing.
Every single thing I've ever done
is about the notion of opposites,
the paradoxical men or men,
east,
West mysticism and
violence and, um, you know,
women without men was the orchard
and the city of [inaudible].
I think that's the only way I
can think in general about the,
the good and evil and all of that.
And so I never see anything in one way
you were named artist of the decade
by Huffington post at one point.
It's a pretty,
it's a big deal.
And you've received a lot of awards and
you've worked on so many things. And uh,
I'm just curious sort of at this point,
you know,
what accomplishments are you most
proud of? Um, and what do you look,
he's interesting. Anytime somebody says
nice thing about me, I said I was, I,
I always considered myself,
um, struggling artists.
I think it's a good thing
maybe. And I, I'm, I,
I know I seen that I do is so hard
to accomplish and we work so hard,
like I work seven days a week, um, and,
and so I never see myself as a success
story and it always blows my mind when
people say flattering things.
I even criticize my work more than
necessary because, not to be humble,
but I just see it that the way
that it deserves criticism, so,
and they flourish when
people say Nice things.
Well,
there are a lot of Nice things to say.
I think we should at this point roll
the clip and then we can open it up to Q
and.
A.
So I'm saying I'm from Egypt.
And growing up you always hear about
her sexual orientation as a rumor,
not like a confirmed fact.
So I was wondering why do you have to
say about that and whether the movie
addresses the issue at all or no?
Yeah, I mean, uh, I'm really glad
you brought that up because, um,
what option you would speak to her
has a different explanation or,
or impression and, and, and
relationship to Amoco. Some.
So what I found also about
her sexual orientation,
everyone says something different.
Some people say she absolutely
was in love with so and so and,
but she did eventually marry her doctor
who, you know, at the end when she died,
she was married to him, uh,
and she adopted a son. Um,
but in Riyadh and many say that she
was absolutely working with men,
but they love with woman. And she had, um,
at the beginning we did a
lot of research about that.
And indeed there was a lot
of images and videos. But,
um, of her really the time that
she laughed a lot and seem,
cause when she was performing,
she was always very rigid.
The time that she was seeing most
relaxed was around woman. You know, uh,
she seems like she
really felt comfortable.
Of course it happens for a lot of
women just even if she not get, um,
but I think everything
hinted at the fact that, um,
for her conservative environment that
she lived there was absolutely out of the
question that she could,
um, be open about it. But,
but also the Egyptian theater really,
you know,
wanted to devour her
personal life in that way.
Like the way we do with celebrities
here, which I really respected. Um,
some people I talked to and say
it didn't matter to us. You know,
some people said, oh no, she was not
there. Some people said, yeah, she was.
But in general, I find that the
status that she reached, um,
it's, you know, like
wildly different, like in,
you have Michael Jackson here and made
his sexuality like the biggest, you know,
American icon as a pop culture,
pop artists.
But you understand that he really was
devoured in the way for his celebrity
status. But the, the customer, they
just loved her music, you know, and,
and it didn't matter if she was a woman
or a man or, you know, gay or not.
And that's what I admired about her
and her relationship to her audience,
that they didn't destroy her like they,
the way we do, you know, Amy Winehouse,
Whitney Houston, it did pay off,
uh, Billie holiday. Uh, you know,
every great artists that we build up, we,
we bring down because we just, you know,
oh, she was very freaky. But in
reality, you know, like I said,
I found that she has this very secret
place that you just cannot take away from
her. And, and people were really the,
the most religious conservative community
just left her alone because they loved
her.
You know,
and I think that's so rare and it honestly
is something I took a lot of pride
that we in the Middle East have an artist
in that level of popularity where 4
million people went.
It was one of the largest funerals ever
in the history of Egypt after Nasir,
I think, um, in the America, in the West,
you have never ever seen this many
people go for, even for Michael Jackson.
So if she, artists just never
that popular and that in,
in a way that she, you know, it didn't
matter her sexuality as you, so much
long answers.
Any other projects you would like to
tell us about that are forthcoming beyond
the movie? That we'll have to wait
a couple of years to see that. Well,
the movie were, as I had
an art component, right.
I'm working on an exhibition in relation
to that, but it will be confirmed soon.
So I would be both for
New York and Los Angeles,
so hopefully it will be all in
2019 and so all we look like,
thank you for spending your
lunchtime instead of eating. Yeah.